So to do soft clustering, we're going to use a similar trick to what
we've used in some of the other lectures, which is to lean on probability theory
so that now points instead of coming from one cluster or another cluster can
be probabilistically from one of multiple possible
clusters. Does that seem like a good idea?
>> It does. I feel a song coming on. Lean on
probability when you're not strongly believing
one thing. No, that doesn't work.
>> Yeah, that almost worked.
>> Almost.
>> Yeah. So that's because it's soft
clustering or soft assignments instead of hard ones.
>> I like it.
>> All right. So to do this, we're
going to have to connect up a probabilistic generator
of process with the data that we actually
observed. So let's assume, and there's many ways
to go down this road, but we're going to go down the road this way. Assume that
the data was generated by, what happens is
we're going to select one of K possible Gaussian distributions.
So we're going to imagine that the data's
going to be generated by draws from Gaussians, from normals.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Let's assume that we know the variants, sigma
square, and that the K Gaussians are sampled from uniformly.
>> Okay. And then what we're going to do is that given
that Gaussian we're going to select an actual point, an actual data
point in the space from that Gaussian. And then we repeat
that n times. So if n is bigger than K then
we're going to see some points that come from the same Gaussian,
and if those Gaussians are well separated they're going to look like clusters.
>> Assuming they have very different means.
>> Alright. That's what I mean by, we'll separate it. Yeah exactly so.
>> Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, okay. Good.
>> Alright, and in particular, what we'd like to do now is say, alright,
well, now what we're really, happening, is,
we're given the data, we're thinking kind
Bayesianly, right, we're given the data and we want to try to figure out
what the clusters would have been to
have generated that data. So we're going to try
to find a hypothesis, which is this case is just going to
be a collection of k means, not to be confused with K-means.
>> Mm.
>> That maximizes the probability of the data. Right? So find me
K-mu values, which are the means of those Gaussian distributions. So that
the probability of the data given that hypothesis is as high as
possible. And this is an ML hypothesis. And ML of course stands for
Michael Lipman.
>> I don't think that's right.
>> Machine learning.
>> That's closer, but not quite right.
>> Maximum likelihood.
>> That I think is correct.
>> Alright. So that's now the problem setup. I didn't actually
give you an algorithm for doing this, but presumably it's going
to depend on various kinds of things and probability theory and
optimization, but is it sort of clear what we're shooting for now?
>> It is, it is. And I actually think the
fact that we're looking for k means probably menas that
we are going to end up tying it back to k means. Maybe so, but
again, it's a softer kind of k means, it's a softer, gentler kind of k means.
>> Mm.
>> I think some people call it K Gaussians. Does that sound right?
>> No.
>> Alright then.
>> I mean it sounds correct, but it doesn't sound right.
>> [LAUGH] Alright then.